foreign
we'd answer a few of their questions and
so that's what you guys get to hear on
the Ramsay show oh George watch out now
we're gonna get this is gonna get oh boy
potentially controversial this is from
inchi squinchy which by the way is that
the controversial part no it might be
depending on how you get offended these
days uh but it is uh it is uh the
username hi Ken my boyfriend of 11
months is not on board with the Ramsay
ways or the baby steps I love him so
much and I'm terrified to break it off
please advise me as if I was your
daughter wow can you hear that she's
squinchy I am now officially the old man
of the Ramsey Show and here's what I
would tell you if you were Josie my
daughter
you're giving me ultimatum and you
explain why
if we're going to go to the next level
in our relationship we have got to be on
the same page about money or else why
are we dating I'm not doing this just to
have a buddy or a pal and so I would
give him the ultimatum to say this is
what I believe about money and if you
don't believe that way I totally get it
but you and I aren't right for each
other and I would say I'm out I got
another one here from Joe Oklahoma State
Joe Oklahoma is his name is it the wrong
time to buy a house right now and it's a
great question Ken a lot of people are
freaking out they're trying to time this
housing market which is so unpredictable
and the truth is there's never a wrong
time to buy the house if you can
financially afford the house and what we
mean by that is a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage with a payment that's no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay and
by the way interest rates are high I
know that but guess what you can
refinance when interest rates go back
down and so that's not the end of the
world I know it's not fun to have that
extra on your payment but if you can
still withstand it with that 25
threshold then yes it's a great time to
buy a house it's a great time all right
here's another one prag land 64 says
guys talk about the court the Texas
judge halting the loan forgiveness this
is big news not much to talk about
except to say I told you so my audience
knows this it's unconstitutional look it
up we learned about this in the fifth or
sixth grade folks this is not political
it's just the Constitution I love that
Ken is like Google the Constitution bro
that's his advice well you know he
doesn't have the authority to do it and
we knew it was going to be challenged so
that's why we tell you to pay off your
loans all right another one George let's
see here
[Music]
uh
can you explain how to win with LinkedIn
interesting George now you were social
media specialist before you became a
Ramsay personality give us 30 seconds on
how to win with LinkedIn number one it's
not just to throw things at people and
just always be posting you need to
engage you need to jump into other
people's conversations be commenting be
messaging really try to connect this is
not the time to do your cold sales pitch
this is the time to actually be a person
and the more you do that the more you
will win on top of posting quality
content on there your insights your
experience that's what people want to
see all right uh let's see Demona roll
if I'm saying that right what's more
important 401k or 529 oh well they're I
have to pay them as separate we that's
baby step four and five you should be
doing both start with 15 of your income
into retirement into the 401K then you
can move to the 529 and put as much as
you can into there by the way if you're
joining the Ramsey show right now you've
popped in George Campbell and I are
answering questions live from Instagram
viewers at Ken Coleman uh if you head on
over there we're doing just Instagram
live questions here's jaradina80 love
the random uh usernames it always
tickles me uh how to become more
confident in your life and work one
simple answer I believe that the key to
confidence is Clarity I don't care what
area of your life it is
confidence comes when we're clear but
when we're not clear and otherwise in
other words we're doubtful
that's very natural to not have
confidence so if it's confidence in
money confidence in your relationships
confidence in your work get clear get to
the bottom of where the doubts coming
from and then address that you're going
to be confident that's good I got one
from Ambit media when should we downsize
our home to be debt free sooner this is
a great question it is not the right
path for everyone and truthfully a lot
of people use it as a shortcut can
because they don't want to do the hard
work and it feels like they can LeapFrog
and for some people it does make sense
but if you can be debt free within two
years without selling the home don't
sell the home because it's a headache
and there's a lot of fees involved and
you got to turn around and then buy
another home and so uh don't do it
unless it's a drastic situation and you
already have way too much house and the
payment's killing you and it will help
you become debt free that much sooner
again this is a hot one I gotta jump in
on Hollis Robinson said I'm afraid to
choose a career I want to make sure God
approves of the career oh
well you know I don't like that what is
the heart behind that well I think it
comes from a good place but God doesn't
uh give us the stamp of approval that I
think we expect him to what he does is
give us judgment he gives us discernment
gave us a heart and I can tell you if
you use what I teach and this job allows
you to use what you do best that's
talent that God gave you it allows you
to do something you love that's the
heart that God gave you and it allows
you to create results that matter to you
again that's that's the discernment that
God gave you that is the approval go for
it uh let's just answer a fun one here
Ken from Jeff by the way if you just
jumped in George and I are answering
questions on Instagram live at Ken
Coleman if you want to jump in if you're
confused by the manic spree that we're
on answering these are fast and furious
uh is it true from Jeff Bush photo video
that George had a real life camel at his
wedding and yes that is 100 absolutely
true I can confirm this and it's not
fake news the 22nd story is we won a
free low local Wedding Contest a twenty
eight thousand dollar wedding package
and so I thought I'm gonna spring 700
bucks to get a guy to bring a camel to
this wedding as a photo op just to be
silly and fun George I got a phone one
for you red sewing says best way to save
for college as a high schooler who has a
small business oh that's incredible well
number one live on as little as you can
make and throw as much as you can into
savings uh you don't have a ton of time
so I would not put it in the stock
market but a high yield savings account
is a great place to store that money as
you continue to work and scholarships
make sure you're applying for
scholarships as an extra part-time job
yeah Sean perriello says how do you stay
motivated at a job that won't train
someone for two years Sally triples
after the training I'd say Sean do you
want to be there long term forget the
two years in the tripling of the salary
do you want to be there long term if you
do
patience it's a beautiful thing wait
crush the now you'll get the next
anything worth doing or getting is worth
waiting here's one from Ben Wilson how
do you get out of debt when you have two
full-time jobs and nothing to cut back
on wow well if you don't have any margin
to throw at the debt with two full-time
jobs you're not getting paid enough at
either of them so Ken would say you got
to get better jobs that's it better
paycheck uh this is fun this is again oh
see you already mentioned this guys but
I think this is fun he may be in the
lobby would you rather fight a one
horse-sized duck or a six duck-sized
horse oh this is a classic conundrum Ken
uh
I gotta tell you I'm going with the
smaller yeah the duck size smaller of
the two I can take them boy there you go
there's my Ron Burgundy moment uh let's
see uh Ken what are the dangers of
remote work what would scare you away I
think two things number one not having
the relationship that you get from
collaboration and being around
co-workers and feeling lonely that could
be a danger of remote work in the second
out of sight out of mind if your leader
doesn't see you hear you and it gets to
a layoff situation you could be the
first one on the Block that is a danger
well we are running out of time I gotta
say this has been so fun going on
Instagram live answering questions live
on the Ramsay Show Instagram myself be
sure to follow us at Ken Coleman at
George Campbell with a K we love helping
people over on social media yeah thank
you for all of that